in this intermediate react course about
react State Management Jack Harrington
will teach you about hook State context
using request libraries for State
Management Redux and more hi I'm Jack
Harrington I'm a principal full stack
software engineer and I am super excited
to be here on free code Camp talking
about my favorite topic which is react
State Management the first thing I want
to answer about react State Management
is
what is State Management so State
Management is basically half of your
react app when you think about it you've
got the presentation side of the house
that's the HTML and how you format it
and then there is the data that's in
your application the state
and to me State and State Management is
the Beating Heart of a react app and why
do I say that well it actually is the
only time a react app will re-render is
when State changes when you add an item
to a cart when you remove an item from a
cart
that's the time when the react app
re-renders and so state is the engine
that moves your react app in fact I
would go so far as to say that reacts
whole job is to turn State into HTML at
least in the web context so in this
video I'm going to give you a complete
overview of all of the different ways
that you can manage state in your rant
application and that's going to start
off with reacts native State Management
this is the hooks we've all come to know
and love things like use State use
reducer use memo and use effect
we are going to drill in deep on these
Hooks and make sure that we really
understand them because they are the
foundation upon which all of the other
State Management models are built in the
second section we're going to talk about
indirect State managers these are
third-party libraries like react query
react location react router it's not
their primary job to manage state but
react query for example it goes off in a
queries data from the server and it gets
it back and now it holds that data which
is in effect managing that state and
perhaps the combination of native Hooks
and one of these third-party libraries
like
react query or react location is enough
for your state management needs for your
application
and then in the third section of the
video we're going to talk about direct
State managers these are third-party
libraries whose sole function is to
manage state
things like Redux
Joe Tai valshio and sushdan and we'll
talk about the different models and
which one you might want to select for
your application
and then at the end we'll talk about
some new things that are coming with
some react rfcs that are just coming out
in xjs13 that change the way that we
think about how we might want to manage
state in our application and I'll sum up
by giving you some recommendations about
what I suggest you might think about in
terms of choosing State Management
Technologies for your app but it all
starts with getting to know react hooks
really well so let's get right into it
so we're going to start off by taking a
look at Native State Management in react
and in particular concentrating on the
use State hook so to do that I'm going
to build a Veet application I'll do that
using yarn create Veet
then you give the name of the
application that you want so I'm just
going to use native use date
and now V which is a awesome way to
create web applications can take
multiple templates I'm going to use the
template for react
right now I'm going to bring that up in
vs code
all right so here we have our
application I'm going to bring up the
console
and then we do yarn
to install all the dependencies
and then yarn Dev to start it up
and I'll click on this link
and there you go
awesome here is our application
it's even got a little bit of
interactivity a little state in this
case but we're just going to remove
everything that we see here to start so
where is that located well that's
located over nap.jsx
and I'm going to remove pretty much all
of this
but we'll keep around you state because
we know we're going to need it
okay so the first thing we want to do is
experiment with using a numeric State a
number and actually a counter is the
best way to do that so we're going to
basically re-implement this from scratch
now all of this code is available to you
on GitHub for free in the link in the
description down below but you can just
follow along me if you please so okay so
here's we're gonna do we're gonna Define
that we have some State associated with
this component so to do that we say you
state
and we'll start our counter off at a
given number so let's start with 10.
now the output of U state is an array so
let's go and get that array
and within that array the first item is
the current value of that piece of state
so we'll call that count
and then the second item is a Setter
function you call that function to set
that piece of state so call that set
count
now let's create a button that has the
count
and let's take a look see what it looks
like
all right so we've got a button down
here kind of hard to see a little bit
but it's got 10 on it but it doesn't do
anything yet so we want to create an on
click so how do we do that
we'll use on click
and then we give it a function so we're
going to say add one is our function
and then we'll Define that function
so here's a mistake that I've seen
people do I've seen people do count plus
plus I think the idea is that well count
is just a count and when I set it it
should be retained so let's try that out
let's see if that actually works
Okay click on that nothing happens
and so why is that well we're seeing
that we're getting this assignment to a
constant variable now what's outputting
that is actually console ninja you want
to go grab that that's from the folks at
wallaby it's a link to that also in the
description down below it's free and
it's super handy like this so well okay
we get it this is defined as a const
right so let's go and redefine that as a
let and maybe that will work
all right let's give it a try
now click still doesn't work but we
don't get an error
interesting okay so why is this well
learning why this is is really critical
to understanding pretty much all of
State Management in react so I want to
spend a bit of time on it and one of the
things I want to do is I want to use a
workbook to show
how this is actually working
so I'm going to create in us another
extension called quokka a
worksheet
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
create a function that returns a value
kind of like you state so call that
function
get state
and let's say that it has some value in
it say 42.
and then when you call again state it
just returns that value
now down here I'm going to call get
state
now currently it just returns 42 but I'm
going to go store that somewhere so I
need to store that in a new value so
like my value
and we'll just ask quokka what my value
is
42. and now if I set it to something
else
now my value is 22. cool but what
happens when I go and get the state
again so I'll say my value again
and now my value again is still 42
because setting the value of a return
just sets your local copy so scalars and
that includes strings numbers and
booleans so a number in this case
are returned and passed by value where
arrays and objects are passed and
returned by reference and there's a huge
difference there
so when you're returned something by
value you don't get it you get a copy of
it which is not the same thing
now you could say oh Jack you know you
got it all wrong this is returning an
array okay fine
let's go try the same thing with array
there you go so
we see that again my value is 42 we set
the local copy to 22 and then we again
set that and there's no difference same
sort of thing down here
all right all we're doing is just
destructuring a scalar within an array
now there actually is a way to kind of
make get state do this and that's the
beauty of JavaScript enclosures
but when you hack around that much
you're not actually representing how
react is actually managing State and the
proof is in the pudding the proof is in
this doesn't work so what works is to
use that set count function that's given
to us
to set that count to be the count plus
one
or whatever you want
so let's go over here and try it again
and now it works perfectly
so now I mentioned the count is
associated with this particular instance
of this component but this component is
the app right so we only have one so
what if we were to have multiple ones of
these let's go and take app and just
rename it counter
and then we'll make a new app it'll just
make a bunch of counters and see how
that works
now we have one counter down here
let's go make a bunch
cool now we've got four count buttons
and now we can click on each one of them
and they all independently set and
that's what I mean by the state being
coupled with the instance of that
component each one of these components
these counter components maintains its
own count and thus
going back over here we can go in
independently mutate each one of these
and they'll maintain their states
individually so we talked about how to
manage a scalar a simple scalar using
use date
let's talk about how to manage an array
so we do that a lot as well so I'm going
to create an array of names and then
we're going to have an ability to add a
name to that so let's get rid of one all
these counters
and I'll create a new function which is
a component called name list
so let's create some state to hold that
list of names
Jack Jill and John
in fact actually let's go fix this to be
const again so that's good okay good and
now we're going to render that state
nice and let's go and actually put it
into our app
all right good looking list there all
right so we want to be able to add an
item
to that array
so we need an input field so that's
another thing you can do you can have
multiple pieces of State associated with
the same component so we're just going
to have another piece of State called
name which is a scalar string
and then we need an input field
now when this text changes
we get an event and that event has a
value for the current target the target
of that event being that input and
within that Target we have the current
value that would be the last thing that
the user typed or the last state of the
text field so we just set the name to
that Target value and again we're using
the setter right we don't want to go and
say name equals Target value because we
know for Strings and for numbers and
booleans we get back copies we don't get
back the real thing so we can't just set
it we got to use that setter set name so
now we've got our set let's go take a
look and see if that works
seems to work pretty well cool so now
let's go and add a button so we can add
an item to the list
now we need to add a click Handler that
is going to respond to clicking on ADD
name to add that name to that list
okay so here we have ADD name so how are
we going to implement on this well what
we could do is we could just say push
the name onto list
all right let's go check this out I'm
gonna go and add some just random text
in there I'll hit add name and nothing
happens
but here's an interesting deal
if I change the state of the component
we'll get a re-render
so if I hit backspace
that's going to change the state of the
name field
which calls set name set name then does
two things
it says the name and it also enqueues a
re-render request for this particular
component
when the re-render happens we get that
same list and then we print it out
now that's the big difference here
between scalars and references
so strings numbers and booleans are
scalars
you get back the value a copy of the
value and then that's it you've got the
local copy but when it comes to objects
and arrays
JavaScript manages those by reference
and when you give react a reference to
this particular array
it then holds not the array data itself
but it holds a reference to that array
and then it gives us back that same
array reference
we then use an In-Place command push to
mutate that data of that array in place
and that's why
as we add more items when we do a
refresh we actually get that updated
data
the problem is that
react has no idea that we've done that
so the second part of what a Setter does
which is to enqueue a request for a
re-render of the component
doesn't happen
so what if we did this what if we said
setlist
and we'll just give the same list again
I mean hey you know we've made a change
let's just go and re-render
okay let's try that so hit fresh add the
name again and nothing happens
so here's the deal when I call any
Setter when it comes to you state
it looks at the old value and it looks
at the new value and if the old value
and new value are the same it just says
I don't I don't care thanks but you know
I didn't you know you're not really
doing anything
so what we're doing in this case is we
are giving it back exactly the same
reference as we had before so it's
looking at those two references and
saying oh that's the same array and so
you're just asking me to do nothing
really and so it doesn't enqueue a
re-render request so we need to do in
order to make this work is instead of in
place mutating the array we create a new
array that has the contents of the old
array plus the new name
so the way you do that is we create a
new array
we give it all of the old array so list
in this case
and then we give it our new name
now we don't have to do that push
anymore hit save
and away we go
even better we can do
set name and set that to an empty string
then after we add it that's set to an
empty string
and it's important to know that with
react 17 with react 18
. these Setters are batched so you do
set list it sets that value it enqueues
a request set name runs right after that
sets that name again and cues a request
to re-render the component react says
Hey I've already got one for this
component and it just ignores it and
then when the re-render comes around
both of those values have been set
now the last thing I want to cover about
you state before we move on to use
reducer is that you state also can take
a function as a starting point so let's
just take our
example here of a symbol string and then
we'll give it a function
and that function will return a string
it says Jack
and there you go now it's initialized to
Jack so the value of doing it this way
is that if you've got some sort of
complex calculation that you need in the
creation of this U State you can do it
all within that function and that
function will guaranteed only ever get
run once when that component is first
created
let's continue to take a look at Native
State Management in react by taking a
look at use reducer which is another way
to store state in connection with a
component just like you state
all right let's go and create another
example application
we'll call this one native use reducer
and again this is available to you in
the GitHub repository associated with
this video
and I'll bring it up in vs code
let's install it
and then run it
and bring it up in the browser okay it
looks good
so let's pair this down again
okay we're all cleaned up but before we
get into use reducer I do want to talk a
little bit about a reducer function in
general and a good way to do that would
be to open up a typescript workbook
and
look at the reduce method on an array so
let's give ourselves an array of numbers
and we want to total of those numbers so
let's start with the total
and then we'll iterate through all the
numbers
and then add that to the total and
eventually well what do we get we get 60
10 plus 20 plus 30 60. I think that
makes sense all right so another way to
do that is to use a reducer function so
numbers
has a function I call reduce
and that reduce function takes two
parameters it takes a reducer function
which returns something and then it
takes an initial value so our initial
value here would be the same as this
total we start off with zero so that's
easy enough
so this reducer function takes two
parameters it takes the current value
which would be zero to start and then it
takes the number at the given index as
it indexes through the entire array so
it starts off at 20 10 20 and 30. so
we'll call that n
and the output of a reducer is the new
value
for the next iteration
so in this case we want to take the
existing value so starting at zero
and then add on each number as we go
through
now if we look at this we get 60 as the
output how cool is that
so this function right here that we pass
to reduce is called the reducer and it
takes two parameters it takes the
current value and then it takes some new
value in the case of numbers because
we're iterating through an array it
takes each one of the numbers as we go
through and then the output of a reducer
is what the next iterations input will
be
so this reducer pattern is going to show
up in two places in this video it's
going to show up in the user reducer
example that we're going to build here
it's also going to show up in Redux so
learning how reducers work is beneficial
across state management okay so what do
we want to do with use reducer here well
we want to rebuild this example of a
list of names and then an input name
and build it all in one piece of State
Management and so we'll bring in user
reducer
and we'll invoke it
and the first thing let's decide on is
what's going to be in the state so the
state is going to have a list of names
start off with an empty array and then
it's going to have the current name
which will just be an empty string
and that is going to be
the state so use reducer just like use
State returns an array that array has
two elements to it the first is the
current state so in this case that would
be this object here and then it also
returns A dispatch and that's a way to
invoke the reducer function that we're
going to add
so let's create our reducer function
and the reducer function takes the
existing state which I'll just name
state
and then it'll take some sort of action
right and that's what's going to be sent
to that dispatch so we'll just call that
action
so my convention action is usually an
object and that object has a type on it
and then you use that type and a switch
statement to then mutate that state and
return a new state based on the data
that you get with that action so
let's just start with setting that name
so create a switch statement
and we will switch on a type which comes
in from that action so when we dispatch
we're going to dispatch an object that
has a type on it
and then we'll create a case
and let's call this one set name because
our first thing is we want to be able to
set that name for that input field so
let's do set name
and now we want to return a new version
of State
so we take all of the existing state and
then we have a name that comes in on a
key called payload and that's a kind of
by another convention you can really
rename these Keys all you want but it's
very common to see type and payload so
the second value that comes out of this
array is dispatch
and we're going to use that when it
comes to our input so let's go create
the input here so we're going to have an
input where the type is text
and the value is the name that comes out
of here so that it's right there we get
state name and that gives us state.name
and then the on change
we are going to dispatch and then we're
going to give it an object and that
object is going to have a type
that type is going to be checked here
we're going to pass set name
and then we're going to give it a
payload and that payload is again that
Target value so the target of the event
is this input and then that value is
going to give you your current value so
let's take a look see how we go and you
know what just to check it let's go and
add in a div worry output the current
state name
all right let's have a look
Okay so we've got our input field over
here
hello oh nice
so what's actually happening here so
what's actually happening here
let's kind of walk through it step by
step is we have an input field it has
the current name on it and then every
time we get a change event which tells
us we have some sort of new text we
dispatch to this reducer function
a type of set name and the payload
that then gets given the current state
which we know is going to be this names
as an empty array and then the current
name whatever that is and then an action
that action has that type in it set name
and then we just create a new object
with that state and that payload
but let's talk about that whole
references and scalars thing and
mutating a reference in place so let's
just say that we're not going to do that
we are going to instead just return
state
and we'll just set the name
to that payload
let's see what happens
refresh
we type and nothing happens and again
this is because react is looking at the
reference that's coming out of use
reducer and saying hey this matches the
existing reference so it can't see it's
not going to compare by contents it's
not going to look at the inside the
object and say look the name is
different between these two things it's
going to look at the reference to the
object so that's why we have to create a
new object here
and then just mutate the fields that we
want to mutate so we return all of the
existing fields which mean all of names
and then we just override the key for
name and change it to whatever's coming
in off that payload so now we need to
allow for the customer to add an item to
the array
so let's create a new case called
add name
and we're going to print another new
object that new object is going to have
all of the existing state again that
includes names and names but we're going
to override names to be a new array
that has all of the existing names in it
plus the name that we send with the
payload of this action
and I think actually also we should just
reset the name to
there see how easy that is we can
actually mutate multiple fields at the
same time it's pretty cool
all right let's go down here and we'll
make a button out of this
call this add name
and with that on click Handler we will
then dispatch add name
and you know what actually we don't
really even need a payload here because
we already have the state so let's go
and just do add name
so this is going to be state.names we
already have just state.name there
yeah that makes more sense Okay cool so
I think that's really clean right all
you're doing is basically say hey just
add the name okay let's take a look
add name and now we don't really know
maybe it added maybe didn't at least it
removed the existing name so that's a
plus
so let's go and see what we have in that
list of names to see if we actually
added a name
pretty cool
so as you can see use reducer is a nice
way of managing more complex state so in
this case we have an object that has two
keys in it you can imagine you would
have an object would have a lot of data
in it a lot of different keys this would
be a much nicer way to do that and you
could go and take this reducer pull it
out of the component code itself and
then test it independently and not have
to worry about testing it through a
react component so I think it's actually
a really nice way if you have complex
state to model that
all right now one more trick I want to
show you when it comes to use reducer I
really like this one so let's go and
call this name list
and then we'll make another app
component
and we'll use name list in there
okay so we're gonna go and make
ourselves a little user form
and in here
we're going to have two input fields
first and last name
so let's make a div
and then within that we'll have an input
type this text and at this point we'll
just say that our value is going to be
some State and State that first and then
we'll have state.last
okay so let's use a reducer for that so
we'll say use reducer
and we won't specify our
reducer function quite yet let's go and
set our initial state to have first and
last
and then we'll get that state
as well as a dispatch
all right great Okay cool so let's uh
invoke user form here and see if it
works
nice we have two Fields there but they
don't do anything
so here's the trick and I really love
this one so what we're going to do is
we're going to combine the state
existing state with whatever comes in on
the action
just like that
it's so easy in fact actually we can
make it just a little easier
how cool is that and now what we can do
is over here
in our on change
we can just dispatch with whatever key
we want to change
so we send first then first overrides
just first but everything else Remains
the Same and the same would last so
let's give this a try over on last
and now you have two fields and let's
prove it out let's go and put uh two
divs down here
first is first step
is state that first and we'll make a new
div for last
perfect
that's sweet so you don't have to have a
whole raft of seed functions using this
little pattern here you can manage very
easily large object State and make all
the mutations that you want it's a nice
pattern when it comes to use reducer all
right so next up we're going to take a
look at two ways to observe State use
callback and use memo so now that we
know how to declare State using use
State and use reducer let's talk about
three hooks that allow you to monitor
state that would be use memo use
callback and use effect
and in this part of the video I'm going
to cover just use memo and use callback
so we'll talk about use memo because I
think it's actually the most simple
yet somehow the most misunderstood so
I like to think of use memo as use
calculated value so let's take a simple
example of a list of numbers
so here we've defined some State we've
got 10 20 and 30 in there in our array
and we want to Total it up and in fact
we want to use that Nifty reducer
pattern that we saw before so how do we
do that well we could just do something
like this
we take numbers we call reduce on it
then with that accumulator starting at
zero we add each number in succession to
that accumulator return the new
accumulator and then that gives us our
total so we just you know actually just
put that down in here
but of course I need to ring in use
state so let's do that
and I'll say like oh there we go total
60. so 10 20 30. together is 60. makes
sense now imagine if you will if this
array was monstrous huge crazy huge
thousands of values well we wouldn't
want to recompute that anytime that app
re-rendered which is what's going to
happen here every time react re-renders
our component the entire function gets
called so what we want to do is we only
really want to recalculate total when
numbers changes so let's bring in our
friend use memo
or use calculated value as I like to
call it so how does these memo work well
use memo takes a function and that
function
does the calculation so let's do that
first
all right so far so good
and then it takes a list of dependencies
in an array
and this is where a lot of folks get
into trouble so basically anything that
you read from should go into the
dependency array so in this case we are
reading from numbers and that means we
want to put numbers in the dependency
rate and what this will do is it will
only calculate this total it will only
run this function
any time numbers changes and in this
case numbers won't change because we
initialize it but we don't actually add
anything to it or change it in any way
so let's run it again
and there we go so there are two times
when you want to use use memo and this
is a really good example of one of them
the first time you want to use use memo
is when you're calculating any value and
the process to create that value it
might take a while so any kind of
complex calculation that you want to do
and in this case numbers could be
arbitrarily large so that qualifies so
no matter what the output is if it's a
number a string a Boolean another array
or an object
that's fine you want to use use memo
whenever you've got a complex
calculation that you don't want to do on
every render you want to just be smart
about it you want to make sure that you
only run it when you need it the other
time you want to use use memo is when
you're creating an array or an object
and that's because react Compares arrays
and objects by reference and so it's
important to stabilize references as
we've seen before in the start of this
video so references are really important
you want to keep those stable so let me
show you an example of that so we'll
start off with a list of names
Perfect The Beatles John Paul Jordan
Ringo get up go while it's awesome and
now let's go and sort those so it
creates sorted names
and you know what we'll just do an
In-Place sort
and then let's help with that
so now I've got the names but you know
what I also want to put the sorted names
there
all right let's take a look uh okay well
let's actually just join that all
together
using our comma
okay all right so we've got a good
sorted names on here but we actually
have the same
sorted list up here so why is that
because I mean we start with John Paul
George Ringo and then actually names
uh-oh okay so what's actually happening
here is that sort is doing an In-Place
sort it's actually mutating names in
place so yeah we're getting a copy of
the reference to that array but that
array has been sorted so the first thing
we want to do is actually copy names
before we sort it
and then we sort the copy all right so
now this looks good we have our original
names and we have our assorted names and
our original names haven't been touched
so let's go back to the code
and let's see so
this is good but every time this
component re-renders it's going to rerun
this sort now that's not particularly
bad in this case because app is only
going to render the once so let's go and
put in a use memo around this again
we'll make this a function
and so what does this depend on well it
depends on names so names changes we
want to rerun that sort
so this use of use memo falls into both
categories of one I think it would be
important to use use memo first it's an
expensive calculation potentially you
could have a very long list of names and
you don't want to re-run that sort on
every single re-render
awesome it also falls into my second
category which is that it results in an
array or an object so this is a really
good use of use memo
let me tell you about when I don't think
you should use memo and that's for very
simple calculations for example let's
think about adding two numbers together
so now we got count one and count two
I'm gonna go add buttons for those
all right looks good let's give it a try
perfect and now we want to get a total
of these two so right now that'd be
around seven right so let's go and make
a total so I'm going to create a count
total
and I'm going to start off by using a
memo and have it add count one to count
two and then I'll just put that in the
div down here
hey nice okay cool I even got back to
seven how cool is that all right so this
is not a good use of use memo and it's
because the calculation is simple and it
results in a scalar a number a string or
a Boolean so you don't really have to
use it at in this case it's really just
overhead in this case so all you need to
do is just do an in place
count one plus count two that's it so
now that you know what use memo is let's
talk about some of the myths around it
the first myth around use memo is it is
somehow connected to react memo the two
are in no way related so I'm not sure
how that happened I guess somebody was
like use memo thinking like
somehow react memo but it's it's not
that it's just use memo is its own thing
again think like use calculated value
and react memo which memoizes components
and is a good performance enhancement in
certain circumstances is just completely
really unrelated so the other myth that
I've heard about use memo is it is a
performance killer and I'm not really
sure where that comes from I think it
might come from the Cs concept of
memoization so with classic memoization
you memoize a function and then
that memoized function remembers every
single set of parameters that's sent to
it and only if it sees a new set of
parameters is a calculator new value
otherwise it will send back a value from
that cache that it has and that cash
could get huge it can get crazy the
potential number of parameters you can
send to it that come into Torx you just
get like a big
data in memory hit use memo doesn't do
that use memo is a single level
memoization all it's doing is basically
saying hey
let's look at this dependency array is a
dependency array the same as the last
time that I saw it if it is then I'm
just going to give you back the last
value that you created otherwise I'm
going to allow you to create a new value
for the new data and then I'm going to
hold on to that but it's only a single
level so there really isn't any kind of
performance or memory hit when it comes
to use memo all right let's talk about
use callback
so use callback is another kind of
misunderstood hook people don't use it
when they should should use it when they
don't need to
let's try and demystify it a little bit
okay so we have this list of names right
John Paul George and Rango and we have a
assorted names use memo so let's go and
create a generic component that sorts in
a list of incoming strings
we'll call it sorted list you give it a
list of strings and it sorts them and
then displays them so first let's grab
this use memo down here we're going to
need that
and so it's now the sorted list
and it will depend on list
and then we will return a div
that has our sorted list joined
cool right
so let's go down here and replace the
sorted names with a sorted list and
we'll give it the list
which is our names
it looks really good and it's doing its
sorting and everything still works so
looks good
so I want to see how often this sorted
list runs so I'm going to make this into
a curly brace function
and just return that sort
and I'll put it in my console log
cool and we can see that we are running
the sort twice but that's because we're
actually mounting the component twice
that's our react 18 thing
when you're in Dev mode in strict mode
in react 18 every component gets run
twice so that's not a big deal
but let's go and click on all these
buttons and we can see that we're not
getting run anymore this component is
re-rendering I can add that to
sorted list render
and now we can see that every time I
click this count we do get a sorted list
render you can see that's 20 right there
we're getting 20 times that call by the
way this is console ninja that's putting
in the console in context like that
it's a really excellent extension and
it's free you should try it out
so okay so now let's go and say that we
want to make this sorted list a little
bit smarter we want to be able to give
this sort function a a sort comparator
so let's say that you want to do your
string sorting somehow slightly
differently so we're going to allow you
to have a sort function
and we're going to send that sort
function on to sort
and now I got to Define that sort
function so down here
we will Define our sort function
and we will say that we're going to take
two strings and we're just going to
compare the two
and we'll pass that sort function onto
our sorted list
nice and so the Sorting still works in
fact we can let's see just multiply this
by negative one and now we get the
inverse we get Ringo Paul John George
but we've actually messed up because we
don't have our sort function in our list
of dependencies because if sort function
were to change we were to give it a
different algorithm we would want a
different result so let's go and add
that to our list of dependencies
so now
let's hit this button a couple of times
and now we can see that every single
time we render
we also run sort
so what's happening there well what's
happening there is that every time that
we re-run app which is every time we
click that button because we set the
state the state then says
you need enqueue a re-render of the app
component that then re-runs this whole
component all the way down the line
and we create a sort function and then
we pass it on to our sorted list
and now the sort function is
the same
implementation each time we're not
changing the implementation but we are
changing the reference every time we're
creating a new function every time that
we go through this
now is it any different if I were to do
this
is there some magic in react that will
make it so that that's not a problem
well let's try
nope still gets called every single time
so there's no difference between doing
it in line like this
and having it called out like that so
how do we stabilize the reference to
that sort function so that when we get
down here to our dependency array
we keep seeing that the sort function is
the same every single time well one
thing to do would be just to pull this
out of the function entirely
put up there now I've got this Global
sort function
give it a try
all right so that works we're not
getting a complete one-to-one map
between rendering and running that sort
but I'm not super happy about having
this outside of the component like that
I don't think that's all that clean I'd
rather have it where I had it before
like right in the component so how do we
do that well we can use use callback for
that
so we can wrap this function and use
callback
and then what's the dependency rate well
the dependency array in this case
is empty because we're not actually
using any data that's in this function
we're not using total or names or count
or any of that this is just a simple
stock comparison function we just want
to make sure that that reference Remains
the Same over time so we're just going
to use an empty dependency array there
that way we only ever create sort Funk
once let's hit save
try it again
hit a bunch of counts
and there we go now we have a stabilized
version of our sort function and we will
only ever call sort of list
appropriately if the list changes or the
sort function changes but we're not
going to rerun it on every single go
so that's why use callback is important
so when should you use use callback but
you should use use callback if the
Callback that you're creating like on
click or the unchange or whatever is
going on to a nested component as a
property so in this case we're passing
sort function as a property to the
sorted list and you don't know the
internals of sorted list
maybe it depends on that sort function
and if that sort function reference
changes it's going to go and update so
make sure that you stabilize references
that you send to a react component if
you're just using a simple HTML element
like input you don't need to use use
callback for something like unchange
it's Overkill
the other time that you want to use use
call Mac is if you are creating a custom
hook which we'll get to in just a bit
anytime that you create a callback in a
custom hook you want to make sure that
you use use callback to do that because
you have no idea what the component
that's going to use that hook is going
to do with that callback and you want to
make sure that the reference to that
callback is absolutely stable over time
all right so the next thing we're going
to take a look at is everybody's
favorite hook use effect so let's talk
about use effect everyone's favorite
hook it's not actually that complicated
but it does have a lot of foot gun
potential in fact it's the hook that is
the one that's most often the culprit
when it comes to infinite Loops inside
of react apps so let's talk about how to
do it right and how to avoid those pesky
infinite Loops so we have a Veet app
here it's called native use effect it's
checked into the GitHub repo and the
source Linked In the description down
below and this is our starting point so
it's just a standard Veet app
currently it outputs nothing but we do
have some extra stuff in here in the
public directory we've got a list of
names Jack Jill and Jane and then we
have corresponding Json files for each
one of our people
not a particular great API but
one of the things that we use use effect
for a lot is to make API requests so
let's do that let's actually use a
combination of u-state and use effect to
fetch the names
so first we have to Define our data that
would be our names
we'll start off with an empty array
and then let's just print it out
let's take a look
and now I currently have names with
nothing because we have an empty array
over here so let's go populate that
array
well one way we could do that would be
to do fetch right here let's go and get
our names.json
foreign
then we get our response back
and then we set the names
easy peasy lemon squeezy let's take a
look
and there they are oh wait hold on
what's going on here
oh oh wow yeah
we blew up so here's what's happening so
we render app
then declares that state names
then starts a fetch then
that goes off and asynchronously runs we
then return our HTML with our names in
it eventually this fetch responds we
then get this
asynchronous then where we get the Json
out of it that again asynchronicity
responds then we do this then here where
we then set the names which starts the
whole process over again because what
set names does as we know from before it
sets the names as state and it enqueues
a re-render so it redraws the names
which in turn runs app which in turn now
goes and gets the new names that we got
so yay we're cool good for that but then
we start another fetch right away and so
we're in an infinite Loop
so how do we get around this well we use
use effect and use effect would allow us
to say hey only go do this thing once so
what does use effect do well it takes a
function
that it is going to call once the Dom is
rendered or really whenever react wants
to call your use effect but I'm not
going to call it right away it's going
to hold it and then call it
whenever it wants to when the dependency
array changes so let's
put our fetch inside that
and then
for a dependency array we'll just use an
empty dependency array we're not
depending on anything we're not reading
anything inside of this use effect so we
don't have to put anything in the
dependency array so let's save that out
and see is this going to work
Bingo it works and this Rock Solid
stable how cool is that yay now it
actually does go and fetch names.json
twice so let's talk a little bit about
why that's happening and why that's not
really a super huge problem so what's
happening is with react 18
every time you it renders a component in
Dev mode with strict mode enabled
it mounts it which renders it
it unmounts it which
in the case of a use effect should call
a cleanup function if we Define one but
we haven't defined one here
and then it remounts it again
and that remounting
calls that use effect again so we get
called twice and a lot of people freaked
out about this and wasn't very weren't
very happy about it but that's what it
is so if you want to not do that you can
actually disable that by removing strict
mode from your app over in the main.jsx
again this only happens in Dev mode it's
not going to happen production but
my people got tweaked about it so there
we go so let's try it again
it refresh and now we only get
names.json the ones
the ones all right now the use effect we
have here is not an infinite Loop this
is a solid use effect a good pattern
let's go and kind of build on this by
taking names and turning into a list of
buttons and we click on the button we'll
go and load the corresponding data and
that will show us how to use dependency
array with our use effect and do it
safely
so we'll start off by mapping our names
into buttons
we'll turn these into buttons
so now when we click on one of these we
want to say that that is our new
selected name so we need some state to
store that so let's call that selected
name
and we'll start off at null
and then if you click on that button
we're going to set that selected name to
whatever name you just clicked
and just to check if this works let's
put that in a div down here
Jack Joel Jane perfect works great
okay so now what we want to do is we
want to go and get the data when this
selected name changes so let's go and
build a use effect
where we look at selected name
and then we fetch whatever name that is
so we'll use a template string here
and then we'll give it the selected
name.json
and let's see so we need some place to
store the data so we need a data for
that selected person
we'll call that selected name details
and so down here
instead of set names with a response
back from the Json we'll do set selected
name details
and we'll just take that data cool
and now we've got our data in there
let's take a look so put it in the div
down here
and we will Json stringify that because
it's an object and react doesn't like
when we just render objects directly so
let's Json stringify that
put in our selected name details and see
we get
all right so we start off with null
that's good because we start off with
our selected name details as null over
here and then as we click on Jill we set
the selected name to Jill
that then triggers this use effect
because this selected name which is now
Jill is different from what we had
before which is null so we had an array
with null in it now we have an array
with Jill in it and so that triggers
that use effect
but here's an interesting little side
note
we also got a null.json request so what
the heck's up with that
what happened there is that we started
off with the selected name at null
and then we came down here and react
said hey cool so we're loading
we don't know what was in that
dependency area before we didn't have a
dependency array before so whatever
you're going to have in here is going to
be different so the dependency rate had
an array with null in it and so it ran
you that our use effect with a selected
name at no which is not what we want so
all we need to do to get around that is
then to just
bracket this in an if and say well hey
only go get the data if we actually have
a selected name
so there we go
but now that I've shown you all this
this is actually the wrong way to do it
because really we are responding to a
user event here we are doing this on
click we have our data right there what
we should do is we should do it right in
the Callback so instead of having
the selected name and then the use
effect
what we should do instead is create a
callback called like on select name
and this is going to be a name
and then we'll just go and fetch that
name
now we can get rid of all this use
effect stuff
and over here we will just
call that on selected name change with
the name
and let's see how it works
perfect
and very reliable and no potential
problem with use effect and this is
something I see a lot where folks use a
combination of state and a use effect
when in reality they're just responding
to some user interaction and they should
just go and do the action right at that
point it's the simplest thing to do and
it's the right thing to do in this case
so you really want to as cool as use
effect is limit the amount that you use
it to just the things where you need it
like for example this use effect up here
okay so let's talk about when use effect
gets a little bit hairy and that's when
use effect depends on data that it also
writes so to experiment with that let's
create a stopwatch component
and what this stopwatch is going to do
is it's going to have a an incrementing
time
so it starts off at zero and it just
every second goes up by one
so we'll return
a div it has time
with the timer on
so far so good so let's bring that down
in here and we'll use it
there we go time is zero cool
so what do we need to do to get this
going well we need to use a set interval
so now we know that over here to put a
set interval right here and just set the
time to the time plus one and then do a
thousand that just like that fetch that
we had before you're going to run into
an infinite Loop because every second
we're going to set that time
that setting of the time is going to
force a re-render of the entire
stopwatch function which is going to get
the new time yay it's going to be one
and then it's going to run another set
enroll
which is going to create lots and lots
and lots and lots of intervals so we
don't want to do that well we want to go
and create one interval so let's go and
use use effect for that
and we know from before that we want to
create an empty dependency right here
because we only want this interval to
get created once
so
let's try this out let's see if this
works I'm going to hit save
and now we go from zero and we go to one
let me stick there
so what's the deal let's put in a
console log and see what's up so we'll
do console.log
and we'll just put in time what what
what's time because that should be going
up and up and up right that number
so it said save
let's go
zero to one
but if we look back at our code we can
see in the console which is out here
with cautional Ninja we're just getting
a time at zero over and over and over
again so what's happening well what's
happening is that we first initialized
this effect when we got our initial
component render and at that time time
the value was Zero and what JavaScript
did was we created a closure here and we
captured time at zero and so now inside
of this function
time is forever going to be locked at
zero so what's one option well we could
go and add time in there
as a dependency so that when time
changes we rerun this and we get a new
value for time
but that's going to run into the same
infinite Loop problem because we're
going to go and create interval after
interval after interval after interval
another option is that there's a
secondary way to call
a Setter unused it
one way is to just give it the new value
another way is to give it a function and
that function takes the previous value
and then you get to return whatever the
new value is so in this case that would
be time plus one so let's hit save
and now we have a working timer
if we were to go into here and put in a
console log
we would see that this number for time
the actual current value
goes up and up and up and in fact I can
make it a little bit easier to
understand by just putting in like for
example like T to distinguish it from
time because time is is captured within
this function but T is just the current
value for time
and there's one more thing to know about
use effect
and that's that the function that you
give use effect can return a cleanup
function and that cleanup function we
are called whenever the old use effect
is getting kind of unmounted or gotten
rid of and the new use effect is coming
in
so in this case what we're going to want
to do is we're going to want to clear
that interval that we've created so I'm
going to capture that interval ID
and then I'm going to return a cleanup
function
where I clear that interval
and that makes this a solid timer
interval I asked actually this question
a lot when it comes to interviews and if
you were to give me this code probably
minus that console log I'd definitely
give you a passing grade on your
interview so of course there's a lot to
understand and know about use effect but
use effect is really important as you
build your own custom hooks or if you
just want to use reacts native State
Management as the State Management
Foundation of your application
use effect is the kind of thing that
you're going to really need to become
familiar with and make sure that you are
very comfortable that yes you can get
yourself into some serious hot water
with use effect but in all honesty it is
an understandable thing and when you
understand the fundamentals of
JavaScript and how they work with use
effect
it actually is a lot less spooky so just
spend a lot of quality time with it and
I swear you will get a lot better at it
now I mentioned early on that there was
this other way of storing state in a
component called use ref so we'll take a
look at that next okay let's take a
quick look at use ref it is one more way
to associate state with a component in
react the interesting thing about use
ref though is that when you change the
value of a reference it doesn't actually
cause a component re-render so that can
be convenient in some cases but there's
actually two ways that folks use ref so
let me show you the first way the most
common way and then I'll show you about
the State Management side of it after
that this is the native use ref folder
in our GitHub repository of
applications if you're looking over
there
so I'm going to bring in use ref
and the first thing I'm going to use it
for is I think the most common use case
which is to get a reference to an HTML
element so in this case we'll create an
input element and then get a reference
to that
so we have this text element and now we
want to set focus on that input when it
first starts up so I'm going to create a
ref a reference to that element by using
use ref and then just starting off with
the initial value of null
and then I will use ref equals and then
just give it that ref
now let's see if this works
okay it looks good we can go and add
stuff in there
but what we want is we want that input
to be initially given the focus so they
get the little linking cursor in there
when it starts up so how do we do that
well we need to one know that the
reference is defined as something that
means that the
component will have rendered and then we
will have gotten a reference to that
element and the way that we know that is
if we use a use effect because use
effect runs after all that happens so
let's bring in use effect
and we want this to only happen once so
what do we do
we give it an empty dependency array and
then within that dependency array
we just focus on the current so what is
current well when you have a reference
you have a current value associated with
that reference you don't just do input
ref.focus
because input ref is itself just a
pointer to current and current is the
thing that you can set or read from
so let's hit save see how we do
and now anytime that the page refreshes
we automatically set Focus to that
element so super easy nice that is the
way that you get access to elements in
react and that's the primary use of user
but there's another use and that is to
maintain State without doing any updates
let's build out an example here so we're
going to have a list of names and we're
going to use this input field to go and
add a new name to our list of names
so let's get that all set up
so we have our use date with our empty
array of names to start let's go and put
that into a div
cool
so now we need a button that we can use
to say hey add this name that we just
typed into this list
so let's create an on ADD name
and we'll assign that to the on click
now remember from before when I talked
about use callback we're not using a
used callback here because I'm just
passing this on ad name function to this
HTML element it's not its own react
component so I know exactly what's going
to happen with that on click it's not
going to create any kind of referential
identity problems like we would have
with passing that on ad name to a nested
react component that made you I don't
know what with that on ad name now we
need to do is we need to go and set
names
to the current names
plus the value of this component which
is pretty cool right because we already
have a link to this input all we can we
can just reach out and grab it
so we can say okay cool get the value
from that component this is called an
uncontrolled input in react and it's
actually the most efficient way to
manage an input you don't have to use
that set and get value
and then one last thing we can do is we
can just set that value to an empty
string cool so let's give this a try
oh looks like it's blowing up let's see
why so I go minority inspector console
uh we didn't bring in use State makes
sense okay so let's go back over here
use date
cool and there we go all right so Jack
and name hey wow so what about userf in
this world well let's say instead of
having just the names each one of these
had like ID one is John and ID 2 is Jane
so you have an ID and a name so it's not
just a name it's it's a structure and
let's go make names sing that tune so
this is going to be name
and then name Dot name not exactly great
fine okay looks good so now there we go
but now when I do add name
Foo this is gonna blow up because add
name I'm just adding the single value
right I'm just adding a string so what
we really need to do is have an ID with
something let's put that to 10 right now
and then a name
there we go
so we want to track this ID and we want
a an incrementing ID Auto incrementing
ID so that's where something like userf
is going to come in handy we don't
necessarily want to use U state for that
ID because we don't really care that the
UI gets updated when we change that
value so we can just
manage the ID using a ref so let's
create that ID ref
by using use ref and then starting it at
one
and now down here
we can just use ID ref.current
and we can just treat it like a value
right current plus plus let's take a
look current plus plus nice and then
down here current plus plus awesome and
just to check let's go and add in the
name dot ID down here
all right so there we go we got one is
John two is Jane just like we set up
right here with the one and the two
and then we have Jack let's see what I
get I get three how cool is that so you
can set this value current without
forcing a refresh of the reactory which
is great of course the only matter in
this case since in all honesty by just
on ad named as a set name which in turn
actually still re-renders a component
but I think in some cases it's valuable
to hold state in a userf like this and
it's just good to know that that's there
if you need it next up we're going to
start finishing up our look at Native
react State Management by getting into
context and also creating your own
custom State Management hooks it's
exciting stuff and it's going to
culminate in US building our own Pokemon
Search application seems like it's time
to start wrapping up react native State
Management before we get into indirect
State Management like react query and
into State managers like Redux and Joe
Tai and all those
but before we do that we need to talk
about context and we also need to talk
about custom hooks because those are the
ways to kind of package and redistribute
state in a native react State Management
model
we also need to talk about typescript
so you might have noticed that I haven't
been using typescript up until well now
and the reason is because I want us to
focus on the model of State Management
and learning about the reactive nature
of State in the native react State model
declaring say using eustate and user
user
and then monitoring State using use
callback use memo and use effect but now
it's time to talk about typescript
because in reality you're probably going
to want to use typescript when you're
using almost any state management system
including react native State Management
so from here on out we will be doing
typescript
so now the native context app that
you're looking at right here is
basically the same thing we've been
looking at so far except that I use the
react Dash TS template invite to build
it so it's the typescript version and
I've also added
tailwind and a Pokemon Json file that
has a list of Pokemon in it including
Bulbasaur which apparently is a grass
and poison Pokemon has all these stats
and we'll be using this data source
going forward as we take a look at how
to actually put all of what we learned
into practice
so that starts with learning about
custom hooks so let's go and build
ourselves a custom hook to go and get
that Pokemon data
so what are the things we know we're
going to need or we know we're gonna
need State we're going to have to hold
it so let's bring in U state
and we also know that custom hooks start
with the word use and so I guess I'll
just say use Pokemon as the name of this
custom hook and custom hooks are
implemented as functions so let's create
our use Pokemon function now I don't
think it needs to take any arguments we
just have use Pokemon and it will have a
list of Pokemon
that it will then return so now we have
our state we'll initialize it to null in
fact actually let's be nice let's
initialize it to an empty array
now the next thing we need to do in our
use Pokemon Hook is to use an effect to
go and do that fetch so let's try that
out
so use effect takes
a function it also takes a dependency
array we only want to load the Pokemon
once so which dependency array do we use
we use an empty dependency array so now
let's do our fetch
and we'll get our local Pokemon Json
file
which will then
convert the response on and take the
data and then we'll set the Pokemon with
that data but of course we don't have
set Pokemon so let's go add that
and now we'll just give it the data
so now we have a problem that we I don't
actually see yet which is that the type
of Pokemon isn't what we expect type of
Pokemon is
a never array so what does that even
mean well it means that
typescript can't infer what this array
is going to be so it defaults to saying
well
never you can have an empty array it has
to be empty for its whole life that's
the only thing that I can guarantee
about
so we need to Define what a Pokemon
looks like and then tell you state that
it's going to be an array of that so how
do we do that
well we Define an interface for Pokemon
so if we look over here Pokemon Json we
got ID name type which is an array of
strings and that all corresponds to this
interface ID name type which is an array
of strings and then all of the
parameters for that Pokemon
and now with this interface
we can then tell you state that this is
going to be a Pokemon array
and the way that we do that is we use
the generic syntax and then we put in a
Pokemon array and now if I look over
here at Pokemon command cageman I we are
getting back a Pokemon array but if
you're like I shouldn't have been able
to infer the type of the Pokemon from
Pokemon Json I mean
yeah it's sitting right there
well no because we get Pokemon Json at
runtime so it has really no idea what
the structure of that is until we tell
it what the structure of that is so this
is your first lesson in Native react
hook typing
honestly it doesn't get a whole lot more
complex than this you notice that
there's no typing on use effect there is
no typing on this use Pokemon hook we
could add return typing if we wanted to
by just saying we're going to have a
list of Pokemon which is going to be
either an array of Pokemon or null but
honestly R is going to have a ray
Pokemon
but that's it so you really don't have
to use typescript a lot when it comes to
react State Management okay so let's see
what we're getting back let's do use
Pokemon down here and we'll get our
Pokemon
and the easiest way to do this and just
find out is this adjacent stringify it
and let's see what we get
and we get
a whole bunch of data nice love it so
now we got our data source let's say
that we want to go and make a Pokemon
list that shows Pokemon
so it's going to take
Pokemon as a prop
and that Pokemon prop is going to be an
array Pokemon
and you know what let's do a little bit
nicer about formatting on this we'll
create a div we'll map through our
Pokemon we'll create a div for each one
and let's try this out so we're going to
do Pokemon list and then give it our
Pokemon
there we go a nice list of Pokemon a
long list a Pokemon what if we don't
want to have to prop drill everything
because here we're doing what's called
prop drilling we're taking data and we
are sending it down as props maybe this
Pokemon list is deep inside of our
hierarchy of react components and we
don't want to have to go and drill that
Pokemon property all the way down and
maybe we have a bunch of different
components that use Pokemon and we just
don't want to have to shuttle that data
all around it's an easier way to do that
and the answer is yes and it's context
that's what we need to do we need to
provide
this Pokemon data down to anyone who
wants to use it and the way that we do
that is we route it through context so
we need to create some context so the
first thing we need to use out of react
is create context
and you know what I'm just going to
start off
looking at context just by creating like
very simple context let's just say like
a theme provider or something like that
so we're going to create a theme context
okay so now how do we use this theme
context well we need to wrap components
that consume the context with a context
provider the way that we do that is we
instantiate a theme context.provider so
automatically when you do create context
you get back a DOT provider and it's a
react element that you can use to
provide the value down any specified
value by just specifying the prop for
the value so in this case we're going to
say dark
is is the value the current value it
starts off defaulting to light so now
how do we consume this let's just give
it a try let's go over into Pokemon list
and try and see if we can consume theme
context so I can show you how it routes
around
so we'll bring in the use context hook
which is how you access context
and in this case we're just gonna
get the theme by using that use context
hook and pointing it at that theme
context
so let's see what the theme is
and the theme is dark nice if I go over
here and I change that value to
light
now the theme is light and we can see
that we don't actually have to prop
drill down the theme we just have that
theme context and wherever we want to
use that theme we just use context we
give it the context and we get the value
back okay so obviously we don't want to
do theming or maybe we do you can do
that for yourself if you like
what we want to do is use this Pokemon
data so I want to provide this Pokemon
data down to the rest of the application
through this context
so I'm going to call this Pokemon
context
and okay so what are we gonna put in
there as a starting State what we could
do is we could say that we have just a
an array of Pokemon because that's the
output of what this of this used Pokemon
here
and let's see does that work so Pokemon
context let's go down here to
theme contextended to click in my
context let's give it a value so that
value
is going to be the output of use Pokemon
looking pretty good now we don't have
Pokemon there so we can actually get rid
of it
and now we can pick up Pokemon
from the Pokemon context
and so I'll rename this Pokemon CTX
and if I look at that then the context
is an object where we have Pokemon
but it's a little easier just to do
Pokemon
and there we go well we don't have theme
let's get rid of that all right looks
good
nice
so now using context we can see that we
can move around all that data without
doing any prop Drilling
but there's a few things that I don't
like one I don't like to use context
directly so I want to make a hook that
gets us access to that context data
that's named appropriately and
unfortunately use Pokemon is kind of
camping on that name because use Pokemon
would be a really good name for that
hook so what I'm going to use instead of
use Pokemon well we could do something
like use Pokemon
source
that kind of works let's do that so down
here
this is going to be the source hook that
has the data in it
and then we can do something like
Define use Pokemon
by just returning the use context from
the Pokemon context
and now down here
we can just use Pokemon
all right it's starting to look a little
cleaner I like that now there's one more
fix up I think we should do around this
context sharing mechanism before we get
into actually kind of fleshing out this
app and using all of the other hooks
that we've seen so the first thing we
need to do is get the typing right on
create context
so the way that we do that is you use
that generic syntax
and what are we going to have in our
context we're going to have the return
type of the use Pokemon Source function
so this is use Pokemon Source we're
going to have the return type of that
and it's either going to be that or
undefined so now we can just set this to
undefined
but now the problem is that the output
of use Pokemon is either
all of the cool stuff that we got from
use Pokemon Source or undefined and so
down here as we use it it's like ah it
could be unfined dude
and you're not handling that but we know
that it's always going to be valid we
know that we're always going to have a
value
so one thing we can do is we could just
use an exclamation point that basically
tells typescript hey it's always going
to be not undefined but another thing
I've seen people do and I'm kind of torn
on whether exactly that's the right idea
but I think it's fine is to instead of
allowing for undefined so we just go
back to something like this
we just take an empty object
and we can take that empty object and
tell and lie basically to typescript and
tell it that it is a return type from
that use Pokemon source so the way that
we do that is we say as unknown
and then as the return type of use
Pokemon Source you kind of have to go
through this two-step with typescript
you know honestly once you get this set
up you won't really see most of this
typing and you just be using it and
it'll be fine so little hacks like this
aren't necessarily that
tough you're only going to have these in
a few places in your code base
all right well I think we've got a
pretty good start here we have our
Pokemon data we've got Tailwind we have
a bunch of knowledge about these other
hooks that we can use so we can make an
application that gives us a searchable
Pokemon index that even looks pretty
cool all right we'll do that next
all right we're starting off at exactly
the same point I've just taken the
native context
directory and it cloned it to Native
Pokemon so if you're following along on
the GitHub this is the native Pokemon
app and what we have is we have a list
of the Pokemon cool
so the first thing I want to do is kind
of refactor this a little bit it's a
little messy so I'm going to go and take
all of the stuff that's related to the
data the store and I'm going to pull
that out and put in its own file we'll
call that store.tsx
pop that all down in there
all right so what do we need out of here
well we need most of it actually we need
to use Pokemon source
and we need Pokemon context and we need
to use Pokemon
cool so now let's go back over here and
get rid of all of that
and then import it from that store
not too shabby let's hit save try
refresh
refreshing I love it but there's one
thing I I'm not quite sold on I don't
like that the app is having to maintain
this connection between use Pokemon
source and Pokemon contacts provider and
I think we can kind of hide that
elegantly by making a Pokemon provider
component I think it's actually pretty
easy so let's go over here to our store
and then we will export a new component
called Pokemon provider
we'll just take children
where those children are a react node
type
and we'll put our children in there
and now we can get rid of the export of
the Pokemon context as well as the
export of the used Pokemon source
nobody else needs to know about them but
us
so let's bring in Pokemon provider over
and out.tsx
and
here we go nice again let's try it out
very good cool so let's make this a bit
Swanky right
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to wrap the whole app in a
centering tag in Tailwind that means
setting the max width of the screen and
then Auto the x-axis so MX Auto kind of
bring it in from the sides so let's take
a look at that oh nice very cool so now
it's kind of in a little bit
so now we're going to model Pokemon in
an HTML sense as a list item so in order
to bracket that you have to have a UL or
an unordered list
and so for our tail end we're going to
say that this is a grid
and let's take a look see how that goes
huh pretty good nice
and then I'm going to bring in a bunch
of HTML which is going to format our
Pokemon and of course all this code is
available to you in GitHub for free I'm
not going to type it all in because it's
just a whole bunch of Tailwind but I do
need to go and add a key
and let's take a look
wow
that's pretty cool
so the next thing we want to do is have
a search box so I'm going to create a
search box up here
and we're going to provide for searching
so let's go and create a component for
this called search box
and we will return input tag in there
give it some nice
tailwinding
and let's take a look
ah whoa that's good looking already nice
so now we need a place to store that
data right we need to hold the search
term
so let's go over here and take a look at
our
use Pokemon Source because I think
that's a good spot for it now we could
just add another item in here for search
and in fact actually you don't even need
to specify a string there just that will
do
but I do want to show how to type use
reducer so let's use a reducer for this
and
let's see how we go so we're going to
use use reducer
and the initial type is going to have an
array of Pokemon and a search term
fair enough
now we need to bring in userducer
cool okay
and we need a reducer right and that's
going to take two things it's going to
take the current state and it's going to
take an action
and we're gonna have that big switch
statement in there but currently it's
complaining about our lack of typing so
let's go and add some typing here so
let's let's first type state so we'll
call this the Pokemon state
so what is that well that is going to be
an array of Pokemon
and then the search string
fair enough that's pretty easy
and then the action let's let's put
together some action so the first one
I'm gonna have is like the set of the
Pokemon itself so let's call those
Pokemon actions
foreign
type where we say set Pokemon and the
payload is going to be an array Pokemon
so now we just need to start
implementing on this so we need to
switch on that action and set that
Pokemon
so we're going to return the existing
state with the new payload
and that's it
yeah pretty good so that's how you type
a use reducer so now the output of that
is going to be the data and the dispatch
so let's get that out of there
the first parameter is going to be that
object and from that parameter we're
going to grab the Pokemon and the search
and then we're going to grab that
dispatch
okay looking good so far but now down
here we have that set Pokemon so we need
to replace that with that dispatch
and what is the type on that we'll set
Pokemon and was the payload the data
so now coming out of this function we're
also going to return the search string
and we just return it
and if I look at use Pokemon and say
what are you getting out of there it's
getting the array Pokemon and that's her
string
so let's go use that so we'll go over
here to our search box
we will grab our use Pokemon and instead
of Pokemon we'll just grab search
and set that as a value
so to see this all wired up let's do
something fun let's call this
set the initial stage of something Foo
yeah perfect
so now we need to have a way of setting
that search
so let's add another option for our
Pokemon action
and we'll call this one set search
and give it a string
as the payload
now we need to switch on that type and
return and updated
state that has the new search in it
easy peasy lemon squeezy but
we need a way to actually dispatch that
and we're not exposing dispatch so what
do we do well we need a set search
function and we need to return that so
this set search function
is going to take a search string and
return nothing avoid
so how do we Define that well we can
come down here
we can say that set search
is Texas our string and dispatches a
type of set search
with that payload of that search
cool and then we return it
but I did say something early on about
used callback and custom hooks you
should always use
callback in custom hooks when you're
defining a function that you're
returning so let's do that let's uh
bring in our use callback
and then down here with set search I'm
going to call use callback
and what do we use for the dependency
array well we use an empty dependency
array because there are no dependencies
if there's nothing going on in here
except for the dispatch which is a
constant and then search which is we get
in as a parameter so there's nothing we
need to depend on
okay so let's go take a look over on our
app
and
we will do set search on that value and
then we need to bring in says search
cool
so that probably works I'm hoping
we'll work on the idea that it worked so
let's get rid of this while we're here
and we'll go back up to our store so now
we need to have like a searched
set of Pokemon
so we have our Pokemon we have our
search term
we need to calculate the
array that falls within that search
so when we think about using a
calculated value what do we use we use
memo
so let's go bring in our friend use memo
and so we'll create a new array of the
filtered Pokemon
using that memo
and we'll return a filter where we take
any Pokemon with a name includes that
search
so what is the dependency array going to
look like in this case
well let's have a think about that for a
second so what are we reading from here
well we're reading from Pokemon so
that's clearly got to go in there and
we're also reading from the search
because we're including search there
so let's give that a go now what do we
do with Filter Pokemon
well we can do is we can just say well
the Pokemon the return Isn't the
original whole list of Pokemon it's just
the filter Pokemon by just saying
fill their Pokemon
so now let's try and filter this down to
bulb and we have just the Bulbasaur
how cool is that see that's the reactive
nature of react State Management
you're creating this connection between
the original data source Pokemon and
that search term and then when either of
those things changes this use memo
triggers and then we get an updated
filter Pokemon so once you get those
relationships set up right it actually
is a very elegant system
Okay so
let's just take the top 20 here because
this gets a little crazy and we've got
800 of these things so let's just slice
off the top 20.
I'll make it a little bit more efficient
all right so another feature thing I
want to
make this case insensitive so the way we
do that is we would lowercase everything
and compare that
cool and now if I go over here and I
type in
bulb lowercase or whatever case it finds
Bulbasaur so case insensitive that's
nice
and then I guess the last thing I want
to do is I want to sort
the
Pokemon on the way out and I think
that's another good use for use memo so
let's go and create a sorted version of
the filtered Pokemon
so we're going to take that filter
Pokemon and we'll just sort it on the
name so we'll do a.name
and then Locale compare that to B dot
name
and so what do we need to depend on well
the only thing we're reading from here
is filtered Pokemon so let's add filter
Pokemon and now we've got sorted Pokemon
and put that in there for the output
Pokemon
and cool now we have a sorted list so
let's see uh Bob
yeah okay there you go so b g s t sorted
all right so this is really cool we've
learned all about reacts native state
management system we've used a lot of it
in this particular example I certainly
recommend if you want to to stop the
video at this point work through this
example get comfortable with it because
this set of hooks you state use reducer
use callback use memo use effect that is
the underpinnings of State Management in
react in 2022. everything else kind of
fits on top of that so if you're using
indirect State Management like react
query or react hook form or react
location those work in conjunction with
these hooks if you're using something
like Redux or Joe tie or recoil or
sushdand
you're going to use a combination of
that and also the native hooks built in
so it's really important to get a
foundation set where you really feel
comfortable with all of those hooks and
in particular obviously use effect which
trips a lot of folks up so now we're
going to get into indirect State
Management by taking a look at one of my
favorite libraries react query
so now that we understand the foundation
of native react State Management it's
time to take a look at third party
libraries and see how they can help us
make our lives easier and we're going to
take a look at two we're going to take a
look at react query and react location
let's go take a look over at their
websites
so here's our current site obviously and
our 10 stack query site now
react location react query are both part
of Tanner lindsley's tan stack it's
really cool so react query is primarily
designed to do is allowed to easily
query data from a server as well as post
data to a server to mutate it
can be used actually to manage any
promise so it's it's a generally awesome
Library there's another one called SWR
from virtual that's also really good I
think react query is currently like 12K
has to be more as 4K so you can decide
for yourself which one you want to use
they're fairly similar react location
is the tan stack version of react router
we're going to use that because we're
going to turn our single page app into a
multi-page app so let's start off with
react query and make it a little easier
on ourselves to query the Pokemon so
let's go over here and take a look at
the inspector
and look at the network and we can see
that when we
refresh we're actually getting
pokemon.json twice and this freaks a lot
of folks out but it really just is a a
matter of being in development mode with
strict mode on so why does this happen
well if I look over here in Maine we can
see that react strict mode is on and in
react 18 strict mode what happens is
react automatically when it first gets
your component it mounts it
and then it unmounts it and it remounts
it the idea is to help you look for any
leaks that you might have particularly
in use effects that you don't close out
properly but the net result is that
things like use effect
which we use down here
if they have well any dependency array
honestly but
people believe that the empty dependency
Ray says that this is only going to
happen on load or on Mount
and what happens is use effect gets run
twice because you mount unmount and then
remount so actually the contract is true
use effect with an empty dependency rate
only ever gets run once
on a mount but it just happens that
react 18 in strict mode with development
mode on actually mounts you twice so
yeah that's why you get two calls but
hey it's fine let's go and replace
basically all of this fetch code
with react query so how are we going to
do that we're going to start by bringing
in the react query Library
get started Let's see we need to install
so we're going to yarn add tan stack
react query
and then I'll bring up the site again
so now what we need to do is we need to
on the app side build a query client
provider as well as a query client now
that query client is basically a cache
so that's actually going to help us with
this double problem because when we ask
react query to go and get that Pokemon
Json for us the first time it's going to
go and get it and then the second time
it's going to say hey I've already got
this in Cache you don't need to worry
about that and it's going to handle that
for us so how do we get that process
started well we got to bring in the
query client provider as well as a query
client Creator from tan stack
and then we'll create our query client
and then we'll wrap our whole app in a
query client provider this is again like
a context thing like we learned earlier
this is just a
context based provider that is managed
by that tan stack
react query so let's give this a try see
if it works
hit refresh and everything is still
refreshing cool so let's go over to our
store.tsx and see how we can use this
well we can use this by bringing in use
Query
from tanstat
and now down here we're going to make
some changes so I'm going to get rid of
this as well as the Pokemon because
we're not going to manage the Pokemon
ourselves anymore we're going to use tan
stack for that so we're gonna get rid of
anything that would be setting the
Pokemon
and initializing it cool awesome
and we'll get rid of our use effect
and we don't need to set Pokemon
all right looks good
so now
we can use use Query so what what does
use Query do
so now we can use use Query so let's
bring in use Query and it takes a bunch
of parameters the first one is a
query
identifier so we'll put in an array
which says that this is going to be the
Pokemon array
so that uniquely identifies this
particular query for caching purposes
then you need to give it a fetcher so
we're going to give it fetchpokemon.json
and then we're going to get the Json
from that request so we have to provide
it with the fetcher it actually doesn't
do that for us which is kind of an
interesting thing but again use Query is
more of a promise Watcher it doesn't
really care what promises you throw at
it so in this case we're throwing a
fetch at it which is the query that is
in the title of the hook okay and then
the last thing we need to do is give it
what the initial data is so when it's
not got the request done what do you
actually want to put in there in the
meantime and we'll just put an empty
array in there
okay that's cool so
let's go and get the data out of this so
we'll get
an object from it
that object contains data
and we can just rename that to Pokemon
but this is actually typed as any
currently so let's cast that to a
Pokemon array
and now we have an array of Pokemon
let's give it a try and see we go
refresh
nice it's that easy literally how cool
is that so we don't have to have that
you state or use reducer that holds that
data we don't have to have use effect
that go against that data we can just
use react query and then let it manage
the data and that's what I mean by an
indirect State manager is react query's
primary job is to manage that promise
but in doing that it also has to get the
data from that promise which it retains
and it stores for us so it manages part
of our data so let's go see if it's
actually solved our double Network call
problem let's go over Network and yeah
now we're only getting that Pokemon Json
just the once even in react 18 in
development mode all right so now it's
time to turn our awesome single page app
into a multi-page app using react
location and in doing this we're going
to see that the URL is going to contain
part of the data because what I want to
do here is I want to be able to click on
one of these and get detail about
B drill or blast noise or whatever it is
and that's going to go to a slash
Pokemon slash IDE
and that ID is going to be part of our
data right it is part of our data model
for the application
so let's go and see how we do react
location
so go over to installation and we see
that all we need to do is bring in react
location
stop the server
paste that line in
start the server again
and so what do we need to do we need to
bring in a few things from our react
location we need to bring in a link
that's what we're going to use to
do the client-side links we're going to
use Outlet which is a way where you can
specify where the content of the route
is supposed to go which is effectively
like the query client so we're going to
create one of those
just like that we're going to use the
router which is a component that wraps
the application gives us that context
and then we're also going to use use
matches the way we can get the parameter
from the route
so the next thing we need to do is give
ourselves a list of routes
now our routes are listed as an array
each array has a path and then an
element that you want to render when you
go to that particular path there's
actually a whole bunch of stuff around
this there's loaders and everything else
there's children elements it is a really
a much more robust system than what I'm
showing off here I just want to kind of
show off sort of the basics so in this
case our current route is Slash and what
we want to show in there is our search
box and our Pokemon list so what are we
going to do with this we're going to go
and wrap our div in that router give it
that location as well as the routes
that we just created
and we'll finish off the router and now
we can take this content section and
replace that with the outlet so whatever
the route is that content is going to go
in here in our nice MX Auto kind of put
it all together if you had like a header
we go above it if you have like a footer
or go below it all that kind of stuff
all right let's uh go over here hit
refresh and there you go so we can try
this out see if that's actually the case
or not just say you know div main route
refresh cool we are on the main route
and apparently we're talking in French
that's kind of cool all right uh okay
let's get rid of the main route there
and now we want our detail route so we
want a Pokemon detail component
detail all right
and where we want to put that we want to
put that on a path
like Pokemon
and then ID and the colon ID means that
anything in the slot here is going to be
assigned to a parameter called ID and
there's a bunch of different things you
can put on that but that's pretty
standard way to define routes and we'll
just point that at the Pokemon detail
all right and then the last thing you
need to do is we need to make each one
of these Pokemon clickable because
they're currently not
so let's go back over here
and we'll use that link
give it the key
say that we're going to the Pokemon at
that PID
get rid of this key
and then finish off the link
and there we go so let's see okay hey
now we've got a little finger let's
click on that
and we have our detail page again in
French but not really okay cool nice
so how do we get the ID from this well
we use that use match to get the ID from
the parameter that is ID right here
so we bring in use match we get the ID
and then we need to get our list of
Pokemon
and then within that we need to find the
Pokemon that corresponds to that ID so
we do a find
and then we do that parts of the end
I'm just going to use plus ID there
because I like that a little bit better
and then if we don't have any Pokemon
data we can just say you know no Pokemon
found or whatever
because we already have the data
but if we do have the data let's
stringify that
and let's see what we get
click on B drill and nice now we get our
data now all we need to do is just
format it so I'm going to actually bring
in a fairly big block to format this and
give us something that you can play with
and have some fun with
all right so I'm going to replace this
div
with this code and we'll walk through it
so up at the top we're going to have a
container div it's going to give us a
little margin then we're going to have a
home link that's going to link back to
slash so we have a way to get back
then we're going to have a two column
grid that's going to have the image of
the Pokemon and then over in the other
one we'll have a bold name so we have
the Pokemon data here
change that out all right and then we'll
have our stats and then we go through
each one of the stats so hit points
attack defend special attack special
defense all that stuff and with that we
create a two column grid where we have
the stat name and then we have the
Pokemon data so here's a little fun
little piece of typescript in here
stat is just going to be a string HP so
on so forth now Pokemon data is a typed
object so it doesn't know that stat is
going to be a key from that type but we
can basically tell it that it is going
to be that by saying that this stat is
going to be a key of the type of Pokemon
data so we're going to get the type from
Pokemon data
which is a Pokemon and then we're going
to get a key from that type and all the
keys in that type are hpe attack and so
on and so forth and so that's why we
don't get any issues with typescript
right there oh nice a cool looking B
drill and all of the information about
it all right so really what are we
talking about here what we're talking
about
as an indirect State manager that in
this case this react location library is
holding the ID of our Pokemon which is
essential data to the function of the
page and so this ID in conjunction with
all of the work that we've done in use
Pokemon gives us an ability to
run that detail page and show the
Pokemon that the person's interested in
so it's a combination of our native
State Management that we've already
built as well as smartly leveraging
third-party libraries like react router
in addition to react location
and if you're doing a lot of forms
management I might recommend that you
might look at something like react hook
form or formick or final form because
all of those will manage the fields for
you so if you have a big form that has
lots of different fields with lots of
different validations you don't need to
manage all the state of the actual form
Fields themselves you can let that
third-party Library do that for you and
not use reactbook form and swear by it
so go check that out
if you look at the GitHub repo that's
associated with this video that's linked
to in the description down below you'll
find a direct Pokemon starter folder and
this direct Pokemon starter is what
we're going to use as we experiment with
these different state managers so what
is this well this is a simple
starter that we have for this particular
application like we have the search box
we got the Pokemon list and all of it is
basically sort of unimplemented it is
waiting for us to implement on the store
and the first direct State manager that
we are going to play with is one called
sushdon it's very popular and is a
uni-directional datamander so I'm going
to go and clone this direct Pokemon
starter and create one called direct
Pokemon
we can get started with it
all right so I'm going to go and copy
recursively that direct Pokemon starter
to direct Pokemon
sushdand
and then bring it up in VSCO
all right now the first thing I need to
do is install sushdand
and I just got it I gotta show you the
homepage resolution this is amazing so
this is the sushdon home page it shows
you a little bit about how to use
sushdon
and I just love it because look it's
it's a bear it's cool I just love this
page so well whatever anyway so okay so
there's our our zushed on the page and
we can see from it how we create a
touchdown store we use create and that's
going to give us back our own custom
hook that's going to manage that store
for us and we can use a Setter to set it
from a method so let's try it out let's
uh go back over here to our source and
into store
and we'll bring in that create
and now we're going to create use
Pokemon
so what do we want in our Pokemon store
well we want the Pokemon list
we probably want a list of all the
Pokemon in the store because the Pokemon
is going to be like the filtered and
sorted version of it we want a full list
of Pokemon so we'll call that all
Pokemon
we'll have a way to set the Pokemon
so that'll be a Setter and you give it
the Pokemon and then we also need a
search string call that search
and a way to set that search
okay now let's
start this up so we'll create a Pokemon
array which is just empty the all
Pokemon array is empty and we'll set the
all Pokemon
to take a Pokemon array and then set
that all Pokemon to that array
and we'll set search to an empty string
and then we'll have a Setter for a
search
so I'm also going to go and set Pokemon
here
because we're not going to implement the
searching filter right away but I do
want to have that Pokemon data available
all right so let's go over to our app
and bring it in so let's bring in use
Pokemon
and then up here we're going to get
search and said search from use Pokemon
now this is one way to do it another way
to do it is to use what's called a
selector so here's here's how a selector
works so let's say we want to get search
in particular so we'll use use Pokemon
and that will get given a function which
gets given the state and we peel off
from that the search
and I think that's actually the best way
to go because what a selector allows you
to do is say hey I only want this part
of the store so only when that store
part updates do I actually want to get
updated and that's a way to kind of
Select down from the store so if you
have large stores that are being looked
at by a bunch of different components
but the components update on different
things they should all use selectors and
I think it's just best practice to
really start off by using selectors
so we also got to get set search
and now we can Implement on this so
search is going to go in the value
and this is going to call set search
with the event Target value got to bring
in the event
and cool all right and then down here in
the Pokemon list
we will have our Pokemon
and we will run it
okay nice let's give it a try
yarn Dev to bring up the server and see
how we go
foreign
so
why nothing well we haven't actually
gone and gotten the data yet but at
least it's not blowing up so that's a
good thing all right so let's uh let's
go and
fetch the data
pokemon.json
and then get the Json from that and then
we're going to call that set all Pokemon
method on that hook seems weird right
but it actually works
so the first thing we need to do is
reference the hook
so use Pokemon and then we gotta get the
state from that that state includes set
all Pokemon and we can use that to set
that Pokemon so let's try it out
all right cool so what this is showing
us is that you have this externalized
state manager in this sushdon hook use
Pokemon
but you can talk to it outside of a
react component context which is one of
the things that we look for in direct
State managers direct State managers
should be able to be accessed by unit
tests or by code that's external to the
reactory or code that's internal to the
react tree and that's the the sign of a
good direct State manager and sushdon is
a very good direct State manager
okay so I think we're doing good the
only problem is that we don't actually
search anything so we click that and
nothing
so let's go make it happen so so let's
go make ourselves a filter and sort
function that takes a list of Pokemon
all Pokemon and a search and then gives
us back the list of Pokemon that matches
that search
also sorted so we'll call that search
and sort
Pokemon
it'll take a list of the Pokemon it'll
take a search string and then
it will filter
through that
and then sort them by name
but also we only want to get the top 10
so let's just slice that off
and there we go Okay cool so now we have
our search and sort
let's go down here to our set all
Pokemon
and for Pokemon
[Music]
we can
call that set in search we have Pokemon
but we also have our search so where's
our search coming from well our search
we gotta go get that so we're going to
you bring in the get
parameter and then we'll call
get and that'll give us the search the
current search
so we're going to do the same thing down
here in search
so we're going to set Pokemon to be the
search and sort of Pokemon but in this
case we don't have the Pokemon so we
need to go get that but we do have the
search
and let's see how we go
foreign
love it and so fast
you see why people really love switched
on it is a very concise very easy way to
make a new
custom hook that manages data for you
externally to the reactory so you can
make it global
but it also integrates really well with
your react app and also with any other
hooks you could use things like use memo
or use state or use a rooster in
conjunction with this you can have
switched on manage the global data and
then any local data managed with basic
react hooks so awesome stuff
so I've talked a little bit about how
sushdon is a unidirectional steam
manager and that's like Redux so what is
a unidirectional State manager means
well it means that the data flow in a
uni-directional data manager only goes
in one way in order to mutate the store
you have to dispatch a action or
call a method on the store that then
changes the store and because you're
subscribed to the store you then get
updated and it only goes in the One
Direction
the next thing we're going to look at is
valcio and valshio is an example of a
bi-directional state manager you can
actually just directly set a value and
get updated if that value is updated
somewhere else so it's like
bi-directional connection to the state
manager if you've heard of mobax valve
Shield is very similar just a little bit
smaller
okay let's go try out valcio
okay so I've cloned direct Pokemon
starter into a new directory called
direct Pokemon valcio and added Valco to
it and so let's go over and check out
valcio and see what it's about well this
is the valcio npm page and it shows you
that basically we're creating a proxy so
our state is held in this proxy
we use a proxy to create that and then
inside of react we use the use Snapshot
hook to connect to that proxy so in the
case of for example a counter we get the
snapshot of the state so that would
include count zero and then when we
click we just
add on to the count we just set the
value and automatically this component
will re-render because we know that we
also subscribe to count over here it's
just a really nice way to manage data
okay so let's go and create our store
based on our
proxies and snapshots
so I'm going to bring in
proxy
from valcio
and we'll create a couple proxies we'll
create the search proxy
by saying we have a proxy and the query
string is an empty string
and then we also have to have a proxy
for all of the Pokemon
so far so good
and now we know we need to go fetch it
so let's do the fetch work
and then get the Json back from that
and then with that Pokemon we're just
going to set that value that's all we
need to do we just need to set all
Pokemon dot Pokemon to that
and let's see so okay cool let's uh go
over to our app.tsx and bring this in
all right so to use our proxies we need
to use Snapshot so let's bring in new
snapshot
from valcio
and then we'll bring in our proxies
from that store
and now let's go get it
so we're going to get a snapshot of the
search proxy and we'll use that as the
value
and then on the change
we'll just set that value
search.query equals the event Target
value so use Snapshot is really what's
doing the subscription to that proxy
it's connecting that proxy with react so
that when search changes this used
snapshot basically fires sets some state
that stays giving back to us as a snap
and we can then display it and that's
how valcio fits into the react rendering
cycle in order to set it you just go and
set the value of the proxy directly so
there's a little bit of a differential
there you don't want to just call like
search.query because that's not actually
going to connect you directly
okay so now here with Pokemon list let's
go and get that all Pokemon
and get that
and now down here
we can just
take the Pokemon from that snap and
let's see are we working
we are of course we got crazy numbers of
Pokemon because we've got all the
Pokemon in the list and we don't search
so how do we fix that we fixed that by
using another utility from valcio called
derive and derive allows us to derive
data from multiple proxies so let's
bring in derive
from the utils
and then derive allows us to create a
new proxy so we'll call that Pokemon
and you give it an object
and then with that object you'd give it
so I'm going to call this key list
Now list is a function that takes a
getter
and then we can use that getter to get
other proxies so we get the search get
the query from that convert to lowercase
and we get all the Pokemon and then
filter it based on that
query pretty cool right so now we can
get rid of exporting all Pokemon
we can go back over here to app.tsx
change it to Pokemon
change that to Pokemon and let's see
snap dot what we call again list
cool
hit refresh
b-u-l-b oh okay well it's not what's
going on here oh okay and on to
lowercase
cool and I think we also slice and sort
right so let's do the slice
take the first 10 and then sort
perfect love it and now we only have the
10. uh great awesome how cool is that I
mean that is a very very simple State
Management model when you set a value
you just set it and then over here we
just do the same thing with all Pokemon
we just we just set it how cool is that
and then use that snapshot to go and
subscribe to it that's very clean and
then this derive I love this so This
ability to just take multiple data
sources and derive some data from it
dynamically that is just great and it
automatically updates anytime that
search changes or all Pokemon changes
the thing just automatically re-renders
I love that it's a another great thing
that I love about State managers like
this
and along that line another model of
State Management that I'm really excited
about is called Atomic State Management
and there's three state managers out
there that really Define the current
state of atomic management there was the
original Library recoil from Facebook
there is the Joe Tai library from
daishikato daishikato just happened to
also write valcio and sushdon so if you
want to subscribe to somebody on Twitter
and learn all about State definitely a
good follow and he's also written a
great book recently on State Management
well I want to check that out
and also there's Nano stores so those
three libraries recoil Joe Tai and
nanosaurs are excellent place to look
when it comes to Atomic State Management
I'm going to choose to use Joe Tai and
we're going to go check that out next
all right so let's take a look at the
Joe Tai Atomic State Management library
and how to use it
in the list of directories that is in
the GitHub repo associated with this
video there is direct Pokemon Johto and
this is where this code lives it's a
clone currently of direct Pokemon
starter and we'll just go through it one
by one so let's go over and look at the
store
and this is we're going to start
building out our atoms so what are we
talking about here let's go over to our
Joe tie page and see how this works so
we bring in atom which is how we Define
a piece of State
and you use atom which is how we use it
in the react context so for example you
have a text atom that you've created by
using atom hello and then you can have
another atom that depends on that atom
such that when text atom changes this
uppercase atom will get recomputed to do
two uppercase so again you're creating
this network of data if you think about
like an Excel spreadsheet or a Google
sheet right you can imagine text atom
would be a cell and then uppercase atom
would be another cell that references
that original cell but uppercase is it
and that's one of the cool things about
this Atomic State management system is
you create this web of state and just
automatically updates itself and then to
interact with it you use use atom give
it the atom that you want to talk to
and then you get back basically a value
and a Setter just like you would with
you state so it's very very simple so
the first thing we want to do is bring
in that Atom from Joe Tai
and let's declare our search atom
fair enough easy
but how do we get the list of all the
Pokemon well that's actually a little
bit cooler and I'm gonna do a little bit
differently than I have with the other
ones so we're going to use this atoms
with query and this
allows us to use tan stacks
query core so it's basically react query
now connected to a Joe Tai atom so let's
go and add
these libraries
and then start the server up again
and then we import atoms of query and
now we just need to create an all
Pokemon atom
that uses that atom is a query so we're
saying to as a query that we are getting
back a an array of Pokemon
we give it a function you give it a
query key just like we did with use
Query before where you give it a unique
key for your query in this case Pokemon
and you give it a function just like we
did before with use Query now we're
giving it that exact same fetch function
to go get that data and that gives us
back all Pokemon
and so let's try this out so we got our
search and we got our all Pokemon that's
probably enough to get started so let's
go over here to app.tsx and bring this
in we'll bring in use Adam from Joe Tai
and we'll also bring in use atom value
use atom value just subscribes to the
value of the atom so we'll use atom the
original which is just like you staged
to go and get the search atom because
we're going to want to set and get that
and we use atom value for the all
Pokemon because all we want to do is
just get the value of that
now let's get our atoms
from that store
and then for the search box let's use
that
set the value
and then here with the event
said that search
good enough now with the atom value
we're gonna go get our Pokemon
on the all Pokemon atom
and let me just display it
hit save go back over to our
display and Bob's your uncle
nice but it was urging so we need to go
and create an atom that looks at both
the all Pokemon atom and the search atom
and when either of those changes updates
itself so let's go and create a Pokemon
atom that depends on both of those
things
so in this case we give it a function
that function takes a getter
and with that we can get the current
value of the search atom by just getting
the search atom the current value of all
Pokemon by getting the all Pokemon and
we just filter so let's go make this to
lowercase
and then we'll use to lowercase in there
and now we've got our Pokemon atom so
let's go and get rid of that export
because we don't need that and go over
to our app and bring in the Pokemon atom
let's call it that
let's get it out of the way
and then down here
all Pokemon becomes Pokemon Adam
hit save hit refresh
b-u-l-b nice perfect wow that's cool
you know what I I do like this Cascade
model
and currently we're just filtering but
we also want to slice and we want to
sort so let's create another atom that
depends on Pokemon atom that has that
so it takes the existing
Pokemon atom
and then it sorts it
based on the name
and oh we also gotta slice it
cool and now we've got a sorted Pokemon
atom and we can go back over here to our
app
bring that in instead and depend on that
let's see does it work
yeah Blastoise started out okay you will
be cool and also is it yep it's trimming
down to 10.
how cool was that so now we can see that
we have this Cascade of atoms in the
store we've got our search atom which is
basically a simple piece of text
and then we got our all Pokemon atom
which is in asynchronous atom that is
based on tan stack query it goes off
makes that query and then sets itself
and that automatically integrates with
the other atoms such that when it
updates any dependent atoms get updated
which includes this Pokemon atom which
subscribes to both the search atom and
also the all Pokemon atom
it then returns for its own sake the
filtered version of that data so this is
how you derive in
this Joe tie or recoil or Nano storage
type system
and then we have another atom that
listens to Pokemon Adam and so we when
you any of these things update like the
search updates you get this awesome
automatic Cascade
and the thing I really like about it is
is that Cascade and it is slightly
different from the Native react version
of that because we already we kind of
have that in the native react system
right we've got you state and use
reducer which are effectively
atom
and then we have use memo which is
basically a way of deriving another Atom
from the original atom the only problem
is that based on the nature of react we
have to manage the dependency Rays
notice that we don't have to do that
here by getting the atom we're
automatically subscribing to it which is
a much much cleaner way to work you
don't have to worry about the fact that
you might have dependency arrays that
might not have all of the stuff in it
that you actually need so it removes
another potential for error
the next and last direct State manager
we're going to take a look at is the
venerable Redux
so I realize getting to Redux at pretty
much the end of the video is kind of
like walking a whole marathon and then
saying hey here's Everest it's just a
little bit at the end no big deal
Redux is a huge State Management
ecosystem essentially Redux is the
longest surviving react State manager
it's been around since the days of
class-based components and probably
actually even before that
and
I gotta say it it can be a little
daunting so what we're going to do is
we're going to use the Redux toolkit to
simplify it a little bit Redux toolkit
gives you a bunch of helpers on top of
Redux that reduces a lot of the
boilerplate which is a lot of folks
gripes with redox is that there's a lot
of boilerplate it also has a react query
equivalent built right into it so that's
pretty cool so we will use that to go
and get our data for us so this is the
Redux toolkit
and what I've created our app
our app is in the direct Pokemon Redux
folder and it is just a clone of the
direct Pokemon starter as we do with all
these
now this is what we're going to add to
the code we're going to add Redux which
is the base library for Redux we're
going to add react Redux which is the
couplers basically between react and
Redux basically just hooks
and the Redux toolkit which as I said is
this simplifying
stuff simplifying functions that allow
us to really easily create stores and
slices so we'll get into that what that
is in a second let me start at the
server
and then bring it up and we got our
search box awesome okay so let's go over
here to our store
and so what we're going to do we're
going to create a Redux store and our
Redux store is going to have slices in
it so now when reacts first started the
idea was you'd have one ginormous store
that would have all of your data in it
and folks got to point where like hey
that doesn't scale really well because
having one big store with all the data
in it for the entire application people
will start running over each other and
so this is a way to slice the data into
parts and pieces so that you can manage
it better
so let's bring in a few imports from
Redux toolkit the first would be create
slice so we're going to create a slice
to hold our search state
so this is just going to be the search
this is going to be the text string of
the search and also a way to set the
search so we're going to create a slice
that slice name is we called search the
initial value the initial state of this
slice is just going to be a search with
an empty string in it and then we're
going to have our reducers
so we talked about reducers when it came
to use reducer this is a set of
functions each one of which is
effectively a reducer in this case we've
got a set search and it takes a state
and an action and the little difference
here with Redux toolkit versus
traditional Redux is that in traditional
Redux you would return a state where
that particular value is mutated but the
rest of it would be really the same but
you return an entirely new state with
all you know new keys whereas in this
case redx toolkit has make it a little
bit easier and then you can just go set
the values in the state and then it does
the merging of your changes with the
original state
this is actually fairly common and this
is actually fairly controversial in
Redux world as far as I know I'm not a
huge Redux person honestly but
you know I'm going to give you the best
I got here so okay
so this search slice has gotten us a lot
of stuff
so let's take like surf slice has in it
actions and a reducer and a name
so we're gonna export out of here the
action for set search coming out of
actions
and now we gotta configure a store that
has that reducer in it
so we're going to use the configure
store it's going to give us back a store
that we're going to export and we're
just going to give it that
reducer from the search so that is how
we register each slice into the overall
store
now if you do store.getstate
which you can do from anywhere you can
do it externally to Redux you can do it
inside the react tree this is all not
connected to react right now you get the
state so that would include search dot
search because it's the search slice and
within that the search value and so the
root state
of this store is the type of the output
of get State what I just looked at so we
do command K command ion that we can see
that our root state has the search slice
and within that the search value
and then finally we want to make a
selector so talk about selectors in the
in the case of sushdon selectors allow
you to go and take a store and get out
just the data that you want for the
particular component so we want to
create selectors for everything that we
need so in this case we're going to
create select search and that's going to
give us back the selector
the value for the search current value
for the search
okay so let's go over to our app.tsx and
start wiring this up to the search box
so to do that we bring in a couple of
things from react Redux now I mentioned
that react Redux are the hooks that
connect Redux to react so here are the
things we need to bring in we need to
bring in a u selector that's a hook that
given a selector goes and gets the
data based on that selector use dispatch
just gives you a dispatch function for
the current store whether you call to
dispatch actions just like we did with
use reducer use the state and use
dispatch use dispatch exactly the same
way with Redux which is why folks kind
of think like oh Redux Redux became use
reducers and it's not that easy but yeah
yeah I mean some of these concepts are
very similar like for example this batch
and then the provider and the provider
is a context you give it a store and
then it provides that store down to
these hooks so let's bring in that store
from the local store
and then let's provide that
I mean I love how Redux is so so old and
it's been around for so long that the
provider is literally named provider
it's amazing like other other State
Management libraries they have you know
read expert whatever you know Library
name provider or whatever query provider
or whatever have you this one is just
its provider it's just provider you
could rename it if you want but that's
what comes out of library and I think
it's amazing okay so we got our store
and now we want to go get
use selector to go and get the search
value so we need to bring in that
selector for search
so I need to use that selector
and give it that select search
and then we also need to get a
dispatcher so we just call use dispatch
and get our dispatcher and that just
basically grabs it from the context and
brings it in
okay so this becomes the value of search
and dispatch we're just going to
dispatch
a set search with the event Target value
so we need to bring in events right here
and let's see actually let's uh go and
set this to a value for sofu
let's see what we've got
hey how's that
and it looks like it's working that's
great
so we've got our slice for the search
part of our Global store
so now the next thing we want to do is
we want to get the Pokemon Json and that
means bringing in the query part of
reacts toolkit so we're going to bring
in
the create API and the fetch base query
functions from the toolkit
query so that's the query part and then
the react version of the query so again
with redox like everything is sort of
there's the the basic and then there's
the react
okay so we want to go and do is we want
to build out our create API for our
Pokemon Json
so we do is we invoke that create API we
give it our path so Pokemon API we give
it the fetch base query so you say that
everything that we do with this
particular API is going to be off of
Slash
and it's only going to have one endpoint
and that endpoint is get Pokemon and
that is going to call query
with Pokemon Json so we're going to get
basically you know slash Pokemon Json
there in fact let's get rid of that
yeah that looks a little better okay
okay now let's take a look at what's in
Pokemon API so inside Pokemon API we
have our endpoints
within that we've got Pokemon and within
that we have our use Query how cool is
that it's automatically created a used
query for us so let's go and actually
export that so we have our
use Pokemon query
and we'll just export that
foreign
and now we can use it
and we'll give it no parameters because
nothing going in
and the output here is either an array
of Pokemon or undefined so let's just
say that if we have put data then let's
use it and if we don't then we'll use
the empty array
not working oh I remember what it was
okay more wiring to be done okay so
we've got this Pokemon API maybe we'll
go bring this down here and add it as a
reducer
okay let's take a look oh there it is
ah yes we have Redux and it's going I
love it okay so now we have uh you know
bulb or whatever cool so let's say that
we want to go and trim that down well if
you look at the Docks
the docs tell you at this point if you
want to derive some data one way to do
it would just be to integrate this with
an existing tool
that allows you to listen to data and
then derive data from that and what tool
we have for that we have good old use
memo so we can use parts of our existing
react native
hook set and integrate them with what we
have from Redux let's bring in use memo
and see how this works
so we want to filter and we want to sort
the data based on the search so let's
first get the search right
in that so we want to filter and we want
to sort the Pokemon
and it's going to rely on the data as
well as the search
and we're going to return out of this
the data or an empty array
if it exit because it might not exist
might be no
filtered
by that name of course we want to do our
little two lowercase thing
foreign
and then we want to sort it
nice
okay so that'll give us our filter and
sort of Pokemon
or an empty array so we don't have to go
check for it anymore let's hit save and
see if it works
so it's giving us 10 that's great and
let's see bulb noise
perfect okay so that is one way to do it
another way to do it is to actually
start the
request for Pokemon Json externally to
the app
and then create a selector over in the
store that listens for when that data is
done and then looks to see if it can
take that data from the search and do
the same thing but do it over on the
store side so we're basically creating a
selector that's doing that kind of work
for us
so let's bring in a create selector
function
and then we will create a selector and
the first parameter is to create
selector are a set of functions that
select out parts and pieces you can have
as many as you want apparently
and the first part gives us our Pokemon
so we're getting our data from Pokemon
API endpoints get Pokemon select
undefined that's the
parameter that we put in and then the
State go and get the state coming in
I'll throw day state and we get the data
okay and then we can go take this
basically
and drop it in here
so we're going to take that Pokemon
and filter it
on that search value
so this could be undefined so let's go
handle that
all right cool so select Pokemon I like
it so let's see now let's go over here
to our app and
instead of using that use memo
we are instead going to just select out
Pokemon based on that
select Pokemon
selector
okay and Pokemon
okay let's give it a try
so nothing so why is that well we've
gotten rid of the query that we did we
used to do this use Pokemon query and
give it undefined that initiated the
query so now we have to initiate the
query over here in the store and the way
that we do that
is pretty much anywhere
we can do
store.dispatch
which is again nice because you can talk
to Redux both in the react context as
well as in the external to react context
and then we want to call that Pokemon
API
with the endpoint
of the get Pokemon
where we initiate it with that undefined
all right let's give it a try Hey Okay
now what's happening is externally to
react we are initiating the fetch of the
Pokemon Json here
and then
when the store updates because that get
Pokemon returns a value it's then stored
in our store and that store changing
then updates any subscribers it looks to
see what the selector is selecting out
in this case the selector is looking at
the output of the get Pokemon as well as
the search
and then using the two to select out
a mutated version of the Pokemon list
where we've filtered it and sliced it
and sorted it so you can use selectors
for more than just selecting data you
can actually mutate the data in the
store and the selector is actually the
right place to do that in this model
okay so one more thing that people love
about this is the Redux
tools so if I go here over here Redux we
can see that
as I type
we are setting the search and you can
see all of the different actions and
this is because I have the Redux Dev
tools installed in my Chrome and I'm in
Dev mode and so that's automatically
registered those things together so
that's that's pretty cool so you can see
like the the pending query you can see
the fulfilled query with the data
it's pretty neat you know and you can
also do this cool like time travel
debugging people think is really slick
dude
yeah nice
okay so there you have it so Redux of
course all the code is available to you
in GitHub in the link in the description
down below and of course in this this
one is in the direct Pokemon Redux
directory now before we get to wrapping
all this up I do want to talk about one
more technical thing
check this out so times they are
changing in react land and one of the
biggest changes has been a recent RFC or
request for comment that would add first
class support for promises to react and
the way that you do that is kind of
different in the client-side code versus
the server side code so in the
client-side code
you now have this ability to use a new
hook called use that you give it a
promise and then when that promise is
fulfilled you get the data from that
promise or I guess you get undefined in
the meantime
so let's try this out because I think
it's worth knowing about this is not out
there 100 yet it is in the experimental
build of react as well as in next js13
so it definitely is coming there might
be some changes between now and when it
actually gets out there but I think it's
worth knowing because it will
fundamentally change How We Do State
Management and react going forward it
adds a lot of new functionality but also
could replace some existing
functionality that we have so I'll let
you be the judge so let's uh go over to
the terminal
and we'll do another create V app
and we'll call this one native use you
know what I'm just going to use just
basic react not typescript for this
bring it up in vs code
and now let's go over to the
package.json and in order to get onto
this new experimental build I need to
change the react and react Dom versions
to experimental
and then do my yarn
and my yarn Dev
and so we now have our app cool all
right so let's go and try this out so
I'm gonna go create a new file in public
called data.json it's going to have some
basic data
and what we want to do is we want to go
get that data so we're going to go over
here to our app.jsx and let's see we can
get rid of everything basically
so how would we do this before well we
do this before by having some use State
and we'd have a use effect and we'd use
the use effect to go get the fetch or
we'd use react query and SWR as we've
seen but now we can do something really
cool we can basically just create a
request here
and what we say data.json
and then we'll get the Json out of that
so now we have this promise just kind of
floating out in space with our data so
let's bring in use
and then we can just get our data by
using that promise
and let's stringify that and see how it
goes
how cool is that that's really neat
that being said
you want to see a browser freak out
watch this so
I mean come on right why not just go and
put that in here
it's like that I mean duh it's gonna be
a lot easier
let's get rid of that
hit save
hit refresh and now nothing happens but
lots of stuff's happening in in our Dev
tools we're going and getting data.json
a whole bunch
so why is that well what's happening
here and let me actually stop our
all right so what's happening here is
that
we run app app then first starts off a
fetch that returns a new promise
and we use that promise
we get the data back the data starts it
null or undefined or whatever and we put
that out and then finally this fetch
actually resolves and we get our data
use picks up on that because it's added
to then to it and it gets the data and
it returns it cool that in turn
re-renders app
and use and then we create another fetch
now it's exactly the same Fetch and I
know I know I know that's frustrating
because it's exactly the same fetch
doing exactly the same thing but it's a
new reference to a new promise to a new
fetch even though that is doing exactly
exactly exactly the same thing it is a
different promise
so
using n says oh give me a new promise
cool all right I'll go away for that one
and so we get is an infinite Loop every
data Json resolves gets us some data and
it's so fast
it never even gets to the point where
react can actually get enough spare time
to put anything up on the screen that's
why we don't even get anything on the
screen in this case and that's why I
initially created the promise at the top
level here because that means that
there'll only be the one the one promise
that gets resolved
now we can go back over to our Local
Host
and it works cool
so there you go so that's use now on the
server side of the house it actually is
a little bit different again so if we
take a look over here at the first class
support if you look for the server stuff
away in server components
and the idea now is that you can have a
component that is server-side rendering
only
in this case called node
that can await
data right in the function you can
create this component asynchronously
this is cool this is huge this is
something we never had before in react
is an async function and react will wait
for this function to resolve because
it's a promise and we can avoid it
and once it's done then the server will
render the page and give it out so this
is really cool and I think there's a lot
of potential here it certainly is game
changing in terms of how it will change
State Management and react
for the better for the worse don't know
we'll see as next.js 13 becomes more
prominent but it is very cool and it is
certainly worth keeping up with so in
summary let me give you some advice on
how I think you should decide technology
choices when it comes to State
Management and react
I think first and foremost for local
state
you should Endeavor to use native State
Management you state use reducer
use memo use callback
at the point where you get to use effect
you might want to think about using a
third-party Library something like a
react query or an SWR because those
libraries are going to probably do a
better job at managing queries than you
would potentially do building it on your
own those are just great libraries
they've got refetching they've got
mutations this is fantastic stuff and
they're definitely good to be leveraged
and I think a combination of native
State Management plus react query and
maybe get server-side props if you're in
the next JS world might be enough for
average applications to manage the state
and then if you have additional needs in
particular to allow for Global state so
you've got different parts of the react
tree
and you need to get safe from one place
to another then you can either look at
doing context if you have a state that's
fairly slow moving I think that's a good
opportunity to move State around using
context or you can use something like a
tuition or a Joe Tai or valcio or Redux
as we've seen and there are lots of
different options in that space But I
think I've shown you some of the best
well I hope you enjoyed this if you have
any questions or comments after all this
be sure to put that in the comment
section
down below and if you like the video hit
that like button and if you really like
the video head on over to my channel And
subscribe to it because I do videos well
not this long but I do good videos and
they come out every couple weeks or so I
think you'll enjoy them certainly if
you're a react Dev it's worth to
subscribe it's free
see you next time